And I mean, I'm busting out of my shirt. I mean, yeah. My leg,
my legs look like, my shoes look like olives on toothpicks, but still dude.
Bustin.
You understand traps, delts,
you name it chest. Abs. I swear to God.
One time I looked really closely to my eyes. It was a little guy skiing down.
I didn't even know they made people that little, but they did.
Jesus made a guy that little and he was skiing down my abs and I just let them
go right down to my deck. Um,
and then just did one of those long jumps off the deck. You know how they do.
He went down some moguls off of my abs,
my little Hawaiian dinner rolls and then boom went down,
sloped off the shaft of my Dick. And when.
He.
So that's the kind of life I'm leading. Uh,
and then, uh, but that's it.
Now one fire just played something off his computer.
It went loud off the speakers, one fire. And that is why he's one fire.
And that's fine if I, yes, the bags are my.
Eyes. Yes. Would I have to check them at the airport? Yes.
Could I put them in the overhead bin? No.
Would they make me tag them while I was working before I put them into the
airplane? Yes. Is it okay? Yes. Does it matter? Do.
Comedy doesn't really matter. Okay.
But it's all good. How.
About the long jumping skiing though? For real? Like what are you doing?
That's some that should've just stopped in the fifties when they were like,
this is exciting.
Did he say you jumped so long and it's so far some of these Olympics events.
It's like what? Hey, what.
The louche Hey dude,
any.
Event that you can literally clip your nails while you're doing it,
take it out of the Olympics. Also.
ShotPut just throwing a ball hat, make it more interesting.
Make it more intricate.
Hey dude. Oh, shot put. Oh, but you know what?
There's a basketball. Hey,
what's the one, the javelin, our really there's football.
Guy, just running submits to cause he's always hopping, you know? Oh,
it's so funny how they hop. So or they throw that though. That's,
who cares? You know, I love how people are like, oh, I love the Olympics.
When the Olympics come out, nobody, here's how, you know,
people don't give a about the Olympics. For real.
Nobody talks about the Olympics when the Olympics aren't happening.
That's how you know. And people are like, nah, I just love to. I love it.
I love to watch one fire, pretends to love it, dude. He, and, and,
and when you never hear about it,
when people aren't swimming or throwing ice picks, you never think about it.
Nobody ever talks about it. Unless somebody got their shot, put like this,
like they're trying to get serviced in the jungle and twisting around and then
throwing it.
People get people talking about basketball all year long people talking about
baseball all year long. People talk about football all year long. You.
Know what people don't talk about all year long, the.
Pommel horse or whatever the hell it's called.
Guys just swinging around, swinging around.
You know that when they do the pommel horse, you know, they're going okay.
Also, what are you wearing?
PJ's Hey dude, why are you in footies?
You 28 year old shoulders for days though. Dude.
Talk about a shoulder workout. If you do the pommel horse, if you do the rings,
you could literally, you could literally rip apart.
People's face.
You go in their mouth and just rip it open and they go like this and you go
traps. That's what you say.
Look at these videos. There's one video. YouTube top my top seven.
Favorite G Ray, gymnastic rings videos. Hey man.
Wow. That's a fan. Oh dude.
Nobody Asian stewed rings. You know why Asians?
Because their legs are for four pounds. Look at the way they do it, dude.
They just to be able to just hold the rings like that, dude.
I mean, how do they do this?
Unbelievable. I got to get good at that. If you can do the rings,
God,
that's so funny that you could be so fit and be so awesome at the rings,
but probably still get no checks, you know?
Cause you're it like he does what girl wants to be like, oh yeah.
What's your boyfriend. Do you want, he does the rings? What? He's a jeweler.
No, you know, it's tube.
Handlebar rings that come down from the heavens.
Also. Why are they always so tethered so high?
Like you could literally have a ribbon that big.
It could be a foot.
I guess I gotta go high. So they're gonna be six feet,
but they're always coming from the heavens dude.
They're always coming from 500 feet up.
Jesus is up there holding the ribbons like this
while the Asian we'll do what we'll do. That's what Jesus is thinking.
So Croatian it'd be good at the rings.
Yeah, dude. It's so Croatian to be good at the rings, dude. You know what?
It's so Croatian to be living so hard to do the
Olympics dude, to be, they talk about, you know,
who talks about the Olympics, all your long Croatians
dude. Every day, Croatians in Croatia say,
well the Olympics are coming up. You'll know. So, ah, dude.
Well that makes me laugh, dude. Thinking about Croatians love in the Olympics.